[موسيقى]
تتطلب الحرب الحديثه بالتاكيد مقاربات
عاليه التقنيه وللاسف وجدت روسيا دعما في
شخص ايران فيما يتعلق بتزويد القوات
الروسيه بطائرات بدون طيار وللاسف تستخدم
روسيا هذه الطائرات بدون طيار ضد البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه وضد المدنيين قبل
مقابلتنا بقليل قصفت اربعه عشره طائره
ايرانيه بدون طيار البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
وقتل شخص واحد واصيب اربعه اليوم وهذا
مستمر منذ اكثر من نصف عام والمئات وربما
الالاف من الطائرات بدون الطيار الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الحال الاجراءات المضاده ضد هذه
الطائرات بدون طيار واستخدام نظائرها زادت
بشكل كبير بنسبه لاوكرانيا من حيث مواجهه
هذا العدوان غير المبرر لكنه عدوان وحشي
لا سيما ضد السكان المدنيين ضد المبادئ
الانسانيه وبالطبع دعم اوكرانيا من حيث
التصدير المعدات يمكن ان تصبح الطائرات
بدون الطيار نقطه تحول حاسمه
[موسيقى]